bottles rocks molotov cocktails
protecting businesses from being burnt
to the ground police precincts being
burned to the ground they're you know
these are all things we can do to
protect
safety and security of every american so
they can pursue happiness here with
reaction former senior advisor to
president trump stephen miller along
with a republican bard from the
committee uh congressman jim banks
congressman am i am i missing anything
here
not at all sean the the verdict is then
the january 6 committee is a complete
dud remember this was all about uh
blocking republicans from winning back
the house majority and keeping donald
trump's name off the ballot when he runs
again in 2024 they they're going to end
up spending over 10 million dollars
they've interviewed over a thousand
people they have a hundred thousand
documents in their possession most of
which they're not willing to make public
and this is the best that they can do
this hearing tonight the the capstone
event the prime time hearing this is the
best that they can do they haven't
proven anything if they've done anything
they've exonerated president donald
trump and republicans who supported him
at the end of the day too you got pelos
the pelosi is doing insider stock
trading you got hunter biden's
legal issues uh you have the this film
crew for stephen colbert coming to the
capitol the the biden doj is supposed to
be color blind instead they they view
everything through the through the
political prism of ideology of those on
the right and left it's a two-tier
system of justice
you know that's what i fear more than
anything else steve miller i mean um you
know look at for example three years
russia lies conspiracy theories a hoax
nobody was really held accountable uh
you know you have on the top of a fisa
application it says verified and we
learned that at least according to
andrew mccabe that there wouldn't have
been a fisa warrant granted if it were
not for the dirty disinformation dossier
from russia that hillary paid for and
yet that was used for four separate
warrants and even after they knew beyond
any doubt that it was
unverifiable they still continue to use
it nobody's held accountable there no
pre-dawn raids guns drawn cnn fake news
cameras i really worry about equal
justice in this country i don't think it
exists
no equal justice is dead in this country
right now what we have is third world
justice
donald trump has been the victim
for six years now of unrelenting
phony investigations persecutions
witch hunts partisan attacks from
congress from the doj from the fbi from
the deep state from the democrats from
new york state it never ends it goes on
and on and on while our cities are
besieged in crime where you have actual
murderers you have actual gang members
killing people in cold blood in broad
daylight but who do they want to go
after donald trump and why
because he's the greatest change agent
ever to sit in the oval office he
brought back our jobs our borders our
safety our energy our military our
dignity our pride and for that they can
never forgive him
and that's where we're going after him
last week congressman
well uh stephen said it well but
remember this committee never got to the
the key questions the the questions that
jim jordan and i would have asked about
why the capitol wasn't secure on january
6. why the the national guard was
delayed why the capitol police were half
staffed on january 6th the breakdown of
intelligence how it was gathered and
disseminated to capitol police officers
they never got to any of that all of
that was necessary to ensuring that
something like january 6 would never
happen again you never heard them talk
about that in any of these hearings
there's a big reason why it's because it
distracts from their political narrative
all right congressman thank you stephen
miller as always thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else